[Musique]
elle reste fragile 6 ans après
l'attentat
ce 14 juillet 2016 Véronique marchand
est venu assister au feu d'artifice avec
sa famille
puis sa vie bascule aujourd'hui pour
vous Véronique quel mot
quelle image définisse ce fameux soir là
[Musique]
malheureusement mon mari au sol le corps
de mon mari par terre ce soir là elle
dit nos restaurants avec son époux puis
se balade sur la Promenade des Anglais
lorsqu'elle voit surgir un camion d'un
seul coup ce camion il est rentré dans
la foule et puis je voyais des gens en
l'air était là comme ça c'est
c'était c'était affreux comme image
mais j'ai dit les freins ont lâché et
j'ai eu l'impression que comme si sa
[__] était coincée avec je sais pas
pourquoi et je alors loin loin de l'idée
que c'était volontaire quoi et
mes jambes se sont figées dans le sol je
ne pouvais plus bouger tout le monde
courait et moi j'étais là je pouvais pas
le camion la frôle elle cherche alors
son mari et aperçoit ses chaussures
j'ai vu les les deux semaines de basket
orange
j'ai dit c'est quoi ça
qui s'était acheté des baskets la
première fois que je voyais ça la
semaine du dessous est orange alors bon
ça m'a et après j'ai essayé de remonter
avec mes yeux le long des jambes et
après j'ai vu un short noir je vais dire
non non j'ai pas possible je pouvais pas
je voulais
je voulais arrêter le temps je voulais
arrêter de
je voulais arrêter de regarder et plus
je montais plus plus ça me certifié que
c'était lui quoi et après quand je l'ai
vu en entier inerte coucher par terre
ça a été l'horreur complète
c'était c'était vraiment
une crise
de folie
un chokiwi une douleur indescriptible on
lui demande alors de partir elle refuse
alors moi j'ai non je veux pas et je me
couchais par terre parce que je voulais
voir si son corps respirait
on devient on devient si vraiment des
moments de
on perd le contrôle de soi
c'est quelque chose que jamais j'aurais
pensé mais pour moi il avait il s'était
sauvé de l'autre côté pour moi il avait
couru jamais j'aurais le imaginé par
terre jamais pour moi c'était même pas
possible je lui disais mais pourquoi tu
as pas couru pourquoi
et c'est à ce moment là que les secours
arrivent et mettez des draps sur les
corps et quand ils sont arrivés à Robert
c'était au moment où j'étais couché par
terre quand ils sont arrivés à Robert
j'ai regardé bien ce qu'il faisait parce
que je pouvais pas y aller j'avais pas
le droit d'y aller
et ils ont mis un drame c'est pas
possible
ils sont passés à la personne à côté et
là il y avait pas de draps alors j'ai
dit lui il va l'emmener
de l'abandonner
une culpabilité qui ne l'a plus jamais
quitté si bien que parfois elle a songé
à mettre fin à ses jours seulement
retenu par sa fille et son petit-fils je
pense que si j'avais pas été là je
serais plus là aujourd'hui parce que
on pense à plein de choses
et puis
quand on est dans le dans le malheur
il y a plein d'idées qui s'ouvrent à
vous
chose que vous pensez pas avant mais il
y a plein de solutions qui souffrent à
vous et puis
on nous dit on n'a pas le droit
parce que ta fille a besoin de toi après
on sait jamais mais mon petit-fils aussi
alors on s'accroche
est-ce que vous pensez que ce procès
peut vous réparer
oui moi je pense que ça peut me à
condition bien sûr du verdict je pense
que ça va me faire du bien parce que
c'est quelque chose que j'attends je
voudrais quand même que que la Cour les
avocats les accusés
sachent la souffrance qu'on a eu en
flagrant et la souffrance qu'on a et la
souffrance qu'on aura jusqu'au bout
demain elle sera à la barre face aux
accusés prêtes à affronter leur regard
prête à raconter ses années d'enfer qui
n'en finissent pas